well Skyscanner Thomas Peter his life
for a sir the prison Otisville New York
is there any a sign of mr. Cohen going
in arrived about an hour ago drove in in
a black SUV he'd actually left his
apartment an hour half an hour and a
half or so before that in Manhattan he
stopped to talk to reporters nel just
summarize what he said he said he looked
forward to returning to a cup to his
family in a country that would be free
from xenophobia injustice and lies at
the helm of our country he said there
still remains much to be told and I look
forward to the day I can share the truth
mr. Cohen of course Donald Trump's
former personal lawyer and fixer who was
about to start a three-year prison
sentence for illegal campaign finance
violations for tax evasion and for lying
to Congress he once said that he would
take a bullet for the president but in
the process of talking to prosecutors
about his crimes he flipped on his old
boss in quite a dramatic fashion telling
Congress eventually that the president
was a liar and a cheat
and a racist and a con man who directed
him to commit crimes to make illegal
hush money payments to silence to women
who were alleged to have had an affair
with mr. Trump just weeks before the
election so mr. Cohen now attending this
prison here in Otisville in upstate New
York it is it's not necessarily the
toughest of places in fact it once made
it onto a list of America's cushiest
prisons